[Musique]
comme chaque année le 4 mai c'est la
journée mondiale des fans de star wars
et pourquoi
et ben non 4 mai en anglais c'est une
messe de force way qui ressemble
beaucoup à mèze force que la fort à la
la que la force du jeu mais vous a tiré
par les cheveux vous avouer je peux vous
avouer quelque chose ait jamais vu
j'aime en nombre pour fêter la
réouverture des salles le 19 mai
prochain
tapis rouge mon michèle laroque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc ça va bien merci dans quel état
d'esprit 13 passes mais toujours ému
comme si un calme et
sur le tapis rouge haie
avec pierre qui m'attend on marche donc
j'arrive charisme pour nous avec vos
potes vous venez de recevoir sans le
savoir une montre rtl
alors ce sera la douzième à je vous en
ai déjà envoyé une assurance non non
vous ne l'avez pas envoyer vos mails
promis j'ai pu vous allez voir que votre
meuble de [ __ ] va être rempli de
promesses
la légalisation contrôlée par l'état
permettrait outre de garantir aux
consommateurs des produits contrôlés
permettrait d'assécher les trafics
éclairé des recettes fiscales et des
emplois elle s'accompagnerait de
véritable politique de prévention en
direction des jeunes pour réduire la
consommation et les risques
c'est d'ailleurs le choix fait pour les
autres drogues légales le tabac ou
l'alcool
je ne pouvais pas ressentir d'effets
quand vous prenez un cachet de co2 ni
prime
moi j'ai compris ce délire c'est quand
même un vous demandez je voulais vous
demander quand même peut-être parce
qu'ici on prend des rails de coke sans
difficulté moi j'en ai jamais eu de
retour
c'est vrai bien servi sur place ou non
mais attendez il ya un moment il faut
arrêter le simple fait de montrer ce
gobelet pour m inquiéter je pourrais
être inquiété pour montrer la
légalisation du cannabis
si vous faites de ça vous avez plus je
suis vendeur pourrait également jouer
des explosions l'envers il est alors
monsieur le ministre ce fait un débat
sans l'instrumentalise passionnel
loin des émotions d'abord c'est un
réjoint que vous avez montré pas si
c'est un vrai joueur attendait ça c'est
celui de dire oui devant moi tu parles
comme ça de rail de coke l'épreuve la
santé vise et jamais personne n'a pris
de la seconde personne de prendre des
drogues dures dans le temps de saisir
pourquoi se priver des pros du doigt ce
que je vais pas trop le sait ça nous
regarde et le cs a bien raison donc
soyons vigilants à ne pas apparaître
comme faisant je voulais l'apologie de
ça se retournera vers moi oui il se
retournera vers 2 mais c'est pas grave
mais en revanche c'est de l'information
il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté là dessus
écouter du rap favoriserait les réflexes
au volant ont turbiné britannique de
sciences comportementales qui a mené
diverses expériences sur la route avec
une centaine de cobayes en calculant la
vitesse de leurs réflexes face à un
obstacle ou un danger sur la route tu as
peur
une voiture qui sait nager
on a fait conduire les cobayes en leur
faisant écouter du rock de la techno
durable du jazz de la musique classique
résultat c'est le rap qui favoriserait
la concentration à les conducteurs qui
roulaient avec du rap à fond ont freiné
en moyenne 16 mètres plus tôt que les
autres face à un danger il faut savoir
que j ai fini très attention et il tient
beaucoup à son vélo il dormait avec la
nuit avant que je n'arrive dans sa vie
attendez attendez il dormait de quel
côté le vélo dans le il dormait à droite
de l'accord oui il dormait avec son vélo
c'est chelou serbie c'est chelou oui
c'est chaud et quand je suis arrivée
forcée manger bouger le vélo j'ai dit au
garage le vélo oui et sauf que le garage
mais il s'est fait cambrioler et du coup
s'est fait piquer son v dans l'ue a volé
le vélo et du film lève j'ai
l'impression victoire in qu'on s'ennuie
pas après 27 ans de mariage le
milliardaire bill gates
c'est l'un des hommes les plus riches du
monde et sa femme melinda gates ont
avancé leur divorce mais ils vont
continuer à travailler ensemble au sein
de leur fondation l'une des plus
puissants du monde ans est une fondation
à qui lutte contre la pauvreté contre
les maladies beaucoup estiment que
melinda va prendre l'équivalent du pib
de la finlande en pension alimentaire
cas on peut rappeler un chiffre un bill
gates est à la tête d'une fortune
estimée à 124 milliards de dollars
fortune qu'il doit à microsoft son
fameux logiciel windows avec de nombreux
jeux de mots à la clé sur twitter ils
n'ont pas prévu de mode sans échec pour
redémarrer leur couple à mon avis il
oublié tout le temps de fermer les
fenêtres
elle en avait marre des mises à jour à
chaque fois qu'elle voulait l'allumer et
en attendant le soleil de fin de semaine
va regarder on l'a là sur le plateau de
télématin le soleil laurent binet nasa
laurent way savard et vous même très
très bien je presque mort mes lunettes
de soleil pour pas me faire et blue here
alors qu'est-ce que tu es l'intention
alors moi le fait indécent individuel
donc du coup tatami croit alors moi je
la roma tisot faisait aussi ton bon
alors qu'est ce que tu as mis alors
alors je mets des phases accord cyril
est circonspect que viennent faire les
fraises doses infimes et un petit détail
que je nouveau cours à bas vu sa tête il
faut croire que christina est passé à
côté de la tendance zip sur les fesses
[Musique]
ya un moment je mange et je me suis dit
je vais me flinguer quoi ouais c'est
vrai vraiment quand j'étais à lyon
d'ailleurs à amiens que je que je
remercie beaucoup que mon directeur
damien lopez est à voir dans cette
langue
oui parce que rien à un moment j'ai dit
mais qu'est ce qu'ils veulent l'année
dernière c'était pour une histoire de
photo
là c'est pour une histoire de dîner mais
qu'est ce que j'ai fait de mal j'essaie
de vivre j'essaie de survivre dans la
nature qui n'aurait fait qu'une bouchée
de zulu mais ici ils sont devenus
complices qui qui s'est même mise à
l'imiter voici le résultat qui qui se
tient debout comme son meilleur ami
droite comme un ami
l'un sans l'autre on n'est rien on fait
toi nous fais toi deux peuples une
amitié hors du commun qui a ses limites
les deux compères sont désormais en
froid
plus aucun regard
[Musique]